[Music]
well hello and welcome to another
episode a special episode of vm end to
end a show where we have a reformed vm
skeptic and a vm enthusiast hashed
things out um the reason why i'm so
excited about this episode is because
you know i have brian with me hi brian
hello hello and that's it it's me and
brian we're going back to day one back
to how it started i'm digging this it's
been a while
it has been a while
so
brian
what are we talking about today i want
to talk about spot instances
which are
okay so they're they're essentially a
discount a big discount um and
like like all things in technology
there's a trade-off
so
for workloads where they can be
stopped
you can get a really large discount
somewhere between 60 and 90 off the
on-demand instance prices
didn't we already have those like with
the preemptable vms
yeah so in in fact these are the yes
you're totally right these are kind of
the the next generation of preemptable
machines so um
in fact they're a superset so anything
you know about preemptive machines is
true except um they no longer expire
after 24 hours all right well i mean
discounts are always good yeah i'm a fan
of discounts always
um
i feel like there's a catch with this i
don't know why so like how come
like people should just use this all the
time is my guess like uh
in fact we were just talking at emma
last episode and she was running
basically her machines for four months
to calculate pi
that was expensive could she have used
this to maybe cut down on cost
yeah i think that's a good example of
where not to use this actually
i think i'm not an expert on that
scenario but you know the most the
machines are being used kind of live as
discs all the time and i think they
probably need to be available all the
time for that full four months so for a
scenario like that or like a database um
this is not a great great fit
where it is a good fit is for any any
kind of workload that can be restarted
that you can stop it and pick it back up
so whether that's a queue of individual
things that need doing
or
um a batch kind of thing that you can
break up into parts and have a bunch of
machines work on and then i'll finish um
or you know something that's got a
checkpointing kind of built in or or
what have you
um anything where that's uh
true and you know you're okay with a
pause in the work
this is a really good good fit for and
you know you can get a really large
discount i think it's the biggest
discount we offer anywhere on the vms
yeah you said 60 to 90 percent
yeah like that's huge that's huge 60 to
90 off yes okay uh that's okay i hate to
be skeptical because that's that's a
great discount i will love it i would
love to use it
but if i was trying to calculate like
how much i'm putting out in expenses
that 60 to 90 percent range is
big so what's happening there like how
does that work so
at a high level we're um we're trying to
make better use of the the data centers
that we've built
so you know we're you know in our normal
on-demand instances you know you want to
be able to run them for four months
straight and not be interrupted and have
everything work you want to have
machines available when you ask for them
all that sort of thing and we strive to
have really you know high slos and you
know have things be very reliable and
available and ready to go
um
in order to do that you end up kind of
building more than are getting used at
any given moment so there's kind of this
extra
that you can't give the same guarantees
about so we want to be
one
be upfront about that let people take
advantage of that and when you have a
workload that is a fit for it could be
stopped
then you know run it there um
so that's that's generally true i think
in in lots of clouds so but then to the
16 to 90 percent thing which is a big
range
so
um the pricing is per zone
and fixed for a whole month so
um where it is in that range
will be stable for a month so if you've
got you know what have you like it's 60
this month and you know 80 next month
and 90 the next or something like that
right in zone you know us central 1a or
something like that right
um
the
but you know pressures change the you
know how busy or not the zones are
changes over time so we want to be able
to adjust that number so that it kind of
works best for sorry for everyone you
know so we're not having everybody try
to run in this exact same place so you
get a kind of a better experience and
and that sort of thing so
um
and
you know that does imply some kind of
extra work um you know if and is not
always available in all use cases so
some things you could just easily run in
a different place maybe if you're kind
of just doing some calculation off of a
work queue of some kind that could run
anywhere
if you have data locality kind of
specific reasons or you know like other
data you're working with
um that's the same thing uh then you
know you may be kind of like less
flexible on that so you'll at least get
the 60
uh off everywhere and that's
a lot and a good place to start but if
you want to kind of maximize it you'll
probably have to do a little bit of
extra checking either manually or with a
script every month to see kind of where
the prices land i mean for for 60 to 90
percent i'm willing to do some extra
work that's that's some big savings
um
my question is that once a month thing
that you know once a month that that
periodic checking that you're doing to
move things around
um yep
what what is it what does it evolve like
am i going into a ui and pushing a
button and saying this is one of the vms
that can die at any moment so you you
can look that up um in our price catalog
and kind of check that out but like the
like where do you do this like you know
how does you know what does it look like
how do you how do you create these
machines that sort of thing
that feels like the uh
my favorite question in technology of
what is it
you know so we talked about what the
benefits are in workloads and that sort
of thing but like no like what is this
so the cool thing is it's it's just a vm
this is a regular vm
and
the spot or not is an annotation
that you add to the creation of the vm
and it kind of lives alongside so it's a
policy that's applied to the vms and it
works for you know all of our regular
vms and and different combinations and
all of the different shapes and cool
stuff we talked about uh before all
applies
um so you can do that you know via the
the web console you can do it via the
command line via the api uh you can do
it in the template part of a managed
instance group uh anywhere you create a
vm
you you should be able to do that
including um you know gke
kind of node pool creation the other
question i have is how do you know which
zone to move your workload to is there
like is there an api to find that is
there a list somewhere
yeah so there's a
price list that you can look at online
or there's a pricing catalog api
um that will show you what the current
prices are
and that will change month to month um
you know we're looking at things to you
know make this process you know a little
smoother over time but right now you
essentially have to look it up either
manually or via an app yeah that's
pretty straightforward i can't get mad
at that um
the the thing that i am a little
concerned about um
so this is designed to offer you know to
basically better utilize
resources on both people's parts save
money for
customers uh better utilize vms for
google
and so these vms can shut down at any
point you said
well how do you test or simulate that
like how do you how do you like as a
developer how do you actually work with
that and make sure everything's good
right how do you know that you're
responding to it properly um so the the
cool thing is that we're
you know essentially just stopping the
vm and so you can simulate it by calling
the api to stop a vm
and the normal thing will happen um
and that normal thing is that you know
we we give a very short but
should be good for most applications uh
kind of early warning and then shut the
machine off so there's a you know a 50
to 60 second kind of uh heads up
that comes through to the
to the vm and then it's actually kind of
like power switched off a lot logical
power switch right um
so
uh
so what you can do is set up a hook
script that that listens for that uh
that alert and do whatever clean up you
need to do close files you know maybe
mark a job as not done or you know
whatever whatever the work needs to be
done to kind of smoothly uh finish that
out and like you say if you want to test
it if you want to
do you know some chaos monkey style
stuff against your your machines and
like shut them down randomly that will
simulate this uh behavior
so then the the question i have is this
is actually taking me back to my
kubernetes roots you know uh where there
was a lot of fungible objects that
weren't exposed weren't supposed to be
lived
and that caused problems trying to
manage and find and work with those so
they created services and basically a
stable endpoint you can put in front of
these fungible objects
how does this work like with these like
vms like if i want to actually reach one
and do something with it how do you how
do you manage your work with that yeah
so let's hold that thought uh because
there's a
the main use cases are not exactly lined
up with that but but there's a thing we
can poke at to do it
the the the most common workloads are
doing
um
you know kind of a
work a task kind of list of tasks so
kind of like um
if you were transcoding videos you know
and you
um
you know wanted to
have a list of videos that needed
transcoding that's a really heavy task
so you probably wouldn't do it in
serverless takes a long time
but also each video is its own thing and
so as long as it finishes it's done and
if it doesn't finish you just do it on
another machine right so this is a
really good fit for this so you might
have a work queue and you start a vm to
do each each transcode right that would
be a good fit so you got this q worker
kind of thing um the other pattern
that's really common is
a pool of workers that are long-lived
and they pull from a queue or you know a
list of things to do so it's kind of
just like whether you create a new one
to do each work or whether you have a
long-lived pool um but often there's a
queueing system of some kind involved
because it makes the job tracking a lot
easier the restart ability
um
now
and and the the pool you might actually
run as a managed instance group so you
know all of your regular compute engine
you know kind of
tools apply so you can make a managed
instance group that is made up of spot
instances as and as the template already
has this spot annotation and so it will
try to create spot instances and when
they shut down they'll be removed from
you know let's say a load balancer or
removed from the work and then they will
be recreated you know at whatever the
pool settings are so if you have the
managers group set to try to run 10 vms
it'll it'll sit there and retry
if the
if they get shut down it'll try to be
running that 10 all the time okay that's
really cool and that that's actually
similar in some ways to the gk thing we
talked about
um was that the tie-in you were talking
about yeah but there's this kind of
corner case where like if your whole
pool is spots and they can be shut down
at any time you might not have something
there to respond on the other end so
what you can do if you if you do have
this scenario where you like say you've
got an api that needs to be up all the
time but you also want to take advantage
of spot
is you could run two managed instance
groups
one made up of on-demand
probably much smaller maybe it's your
kind of like baseline
and then one made up of spot
uh is your kind of turbo mode or
whatever what have you right and they
both live behind the same api so you can
you know
count on there being some machines up
and people get a response
but you know in best case scenario it's
faster or like you know the transcodes
happen faster or what have you like i
don't know what we're going to do next
in the future but i hope we get to work
or do something like that because that's
i want to know how to like build that
that's cool
um i did have a question speaking of
these queues and the workers
um if you have these vms do you have any
uh like kind of guarantee of how long
they're going to be up for or
no i'm shaking my head here but like
that's that's the trade-off to this is
that when you
when you create one of these uh vms it
could get shut down at any time um and
and that's the
the the design trade-off for this um
including pretty much right away like
you start it and it gets shut down right
away now normally you know they'll run
for quite a while um
but you need to be ready for them to
turn off at any you know what i think
it's a fair trade-off though for the the
60 to 90
off wow so
again you've done it again you've
convinced me i want to go try this i
want to go see how it works i want to
maybe make two separate management
access groups and see what happens so
how do i get started the
real place to start is actually on your
team so not even like technology wise
about like google cloud or anything but
look around at the workloads you have
and see
are there already workloads that are you
know essentially kind of workers
responding to a queue or very batch
oriented things that might be a good fit
for this those are going to be the
easiest to kind of translate over and
it's
really worth looking at like you could
save significant money and maybe you
have to make a few changes or like add
you know a restart somewhere or some
extra logging it's probably worth the
time to do um
so look around and see what there are
and maybe you have some things that
might be a little extra step like this
kind of two-stage thing we talked about
and decide whether that's worth doing um
and then try it out like and you can
kind of prove to yourself that it works
just through the web console just you
know
say this is going to be a spot instance
or you know do it through um g cloud try
it out see how it works check out the
docs on how to respond to shutdowns and
give it a try ryan you you haven't led
me wrong yet it's been two seasons three
now and counting so uh definitely going
to do this thank you so much for coming
in today uh always always i always love
it i always log in to do this with you
the
likewise the the thing what about next
week what are we
any any clues any giveaways yeah
no giveaways but we will have a real
guest that's what i'll say
not just you are a real guest thank you
though for coming in as always and uh if
you're watching at home
or on the bus wherever you might be
thank you
[Music]